Now that we have covered arrangement of digits,
let's try arranging people.
Say we have five people.
And we have just three chairs.
The chairs are placed in a row or in a straight line.
Five people and three chairs.
With this situation, in how many ways do you think
can these chairs be occupied?
Now if you've gone through our previous sessions
on forming numbers,
you should quickly realize that this problem is not too different.
Five people is analogous to five different digits.
And three chairs are analogous to the three slots,
for the three digit number we had to form.
Correct!
If you remember,
we were given five digits
and asked for the number of three digit numbers we can form.
Here we have been given five people
and have been asked for the number of ways
in which we can arrange any three of them
on these three chairs.
It's exactly the same.
Just that they have used chairs and people
instead of numbers and digits.
So assume that these three chairs are like three slots.
In how many ways can we fill the first slot?
Understand the question well.
If we have five people and all three chairs are empty.
In how many ways can the first chair be occupied?
It's logic!
Any one of the five people can be seated on this chair.
It's obvious!
The chair can be occupied in five ways.
So out of the five people,
one person is seated on the first chair now.
Now one person having taken the seat,
in how many ways can the second chair be occupied?
One person is seated here.
It means one of the five people is seated on the first chair.
And any one of the remaining four can be seated on the second.
Once the first chair is occupied,
the second chair can be filled in four ways.
You should be able to answer the next question.
Assuming one person is seated on the first chair,
and another on the second,
in how many ways can the third chair be occupied?
It's easy.
Two out of the five are seated on the first two chairs.
Only three remain.
If one person is seated on the first chair
and another on the second,
then the third chair can be occupied by any one
of the remaining three people.
Three ways.
In our first session based on permutations and combinations,
we discussed the two important rules of counting.
'And' is multiplication 'Or' is addition.
So do we multiply these or add them?
To know the answer just read out what you have solved.
Will it be filling the first or the second or the third chair?
Or will it be filling the first and the second and the third chair?
Of course it will be 'and'.
We need to look at the ways in which all three chairs are occupied.
So we multiply these ways.
And we get the answer as 60 ways.
If there are five people,
then there are 60 ways
in which these three chairs can be occupied.
Let me modify the question a bit.
This time we have five people,
and we have been provided with five chairs.
Again the chairs are in a row.
In how many ways can the chairs be occupied?
What does this mean?
In simple words the question is asking us
for all possible arrangements of five people on these five chairs.
Again, let's take these five chairs as five slots.
And using our usual technique, let's go slot by slot.
In how many ways can the first chair be occupied?
Any one of the five people can be seated on the first chair.
So there are five different ways,
in which the first chair can be occupied.
Understand the situation now.
One of these five is seated on the first chair.
Once this has happened,
in how many ways can the second chair be occupied?
As there are four people remaining,
one of those four can be seated on the second chair.
The second chair can be occupied in four ways.
Once these two chairs are occupied,
the third one can be occupied in three ways.
And similarly, two ways for the fourth chair,
and just one person remains for the fifth one.
One way in which the fifth chair can be occupied,
if four people are seated in the initial four.
And to get the answer,
we multiply these ways.
Five times four is 20,
20 times 3 is 60,
and 60 times 2 is 120.
120 ways is the answer.
120 ways in which five people can occupy five chairs.
This is also equal to five factorial.
Now books would ask you to memorise this.
Arranging five people on five chairs as five factorial.
Or 'N people' on 'N chairs' as 'N factorial'.
But don't memorise this.
You have to understand how we arrived at a 5 factorial.
After watching this video,
I am sure you've understood why.
But if this video was a little too fast for you,
please go through it again
as many questions are built around this concept.